so the chart tells you I'm Glenn Henry I
come from a little company called
centaur technology which I'll tell you
about the word technology is over you so
I thought I'd describe what we have we
have a chip it runs it's been
demonstrated at a tradeshow but it's not
a product and what I'm talking about
today is hardware at least 90% Hardware
yeah the deep learning or AI world is
dominated by inventions and software but
they still have to run on something so
that's what they're for there's our part
at a trade show and if you can see the
picture it's running a variety of
standard object detection kinds of that
are better applications since our
technology is this will be our 25th
anniversary is started by myself and
three other people who left Dale with
the idea to go to low-cost x86 processor
which we have done for 25 years no one
has heard of us but with that I have a
list here of people you've heard of HP
Dell IBM etc which have actually used
our parts over those 25 years we're only
about a hundred people but we contain
everything necessary to be able to
custom SOC which I'll show you not just
the logic and architecture but circuit
design DB manufacturing engineering and
so forth so that's centaur this is what
I'm going to tell you what we built
that's the what but I want to start by
talking about the why we built it
whatever I got a lot of presentations
and know whatever is presented is
obsolete usually in two to three years
that why they chose what they chose is I
think important in learning how to build
the next thing so I'll talk a little
the philosophy or objectives and then
I'll tell you what it is and show you
some pitch mark results and what have
you
history is we started a new process for
three years ago it was almost a from
scratch we call it CH a and I decided
that that processor should have a
coprocessor to accelerate deep learning
inference the reasons are obvious I have
actually used this chart before and I
had a whole list of reasons that I
realized it's obvious that one should do
it so I took the reasons out our
challenges are there was nothing to copy
we had to invent something and we didn't
have any people to work on it so we're a
small company we make do I did the
hardware architecture and the RTO myself
got a build guy so two of us did the
hardware we did hire someone who knew
something Parviz and we rounded up a
bunch of our really smart we have a very
good relationship with UT University of
Texas and we pretty much able to hire
their best and brightest we had a bunch
of you know new hires and they put
together our software team and I think
when you see what we've done it's pretty
impressive and that team was quite good
and we decided to design the
architecture from scratch and there's
three key words there that sort of
dominated our of our thinking one was
flexible because this field is moving
rapidly there's a paper every day and
every week there's a paper that it's
really good and even in the three years
since we started things have changed a
lot so we wanted something that had legs
for the future in it something we could
modify easily the other couple of things
that are important to us was efficiency
this was a coprocessor being attached to
something and at the start we had no
idea how much space we would have this
was not the main focus
this joke in fact this was often called
Glenn's folly in the early days because
you know was just something that small
team was doing on the side so we had to
be able to fit in lots of different
holes and we obviously had to be very
efficient we're not gonna have a wafer
scaled chip like some people in the
industry however monster chips and we
have to deal with the coprocessor so I'm
going to talk a little bit about why
co-processing is wonderful and some of
the challenges that go with it by the
way if you people that are here have
questions just call them out
oh no this is that alright so why a
coprocessor it's almost free first of
all there's a whole bunch of stuff that
is already on the chip you don't have to
pay for including the cost of the chip
itself in addition there's usually and I
think when you see that I thought of our
chip there's you can see there's usually
some spare space on these chips because
of pens and other considerations so the
the space you take in a coprocessors not
all costly but even so at the worst case
you're paying for just square
millimetres of a much larger guy there
are no extra pins there's no extra
package its G and in our case and we
took advantage of this intentionally is
the fact that we have it's a coprocessor
and I'll show how it's attached to it
turns out to be 8 reasonably high
performance x86 cores and so you can use
up scores to do things you don't want to
do in the specialized hardware you can
use it to prototyping the functions etc
so you get an advantage that way and
from a customer viewpoint I put the
sales job down on the bottom it's always
there you don't have to buy new chips
you don't have to add a PCI device you
don't have to do anything it's there and
as you'll see it has good performance
and to us it has negligible Delta cost
why doesn't everyone do it
well all those things you got for free
you have to live with them like power
distribution the clock distribution the
speeds things like that and it turns out
there's not a good process coprocessor
architecture in the x86 world that does
help should talk to it how it talks to
other things and so we had to invent
that and we're inherently limited in
performance how it turns out that's not
a big problem we think our performance
is good enough but there are devices you
can buy out there for thousand dollars
or more that have super fast memories
cheating GDD our memories and there's a
lot of people in the industry probably a
hundred startups trying to be able to
chip and the chips are huge how many of
those become chips this remains to be
seen
we don't have that luxury and therefore
efficiency giving the maximum
performance per you know square
millimetre was very important to us the
objectives that we had at the start and
they're still our objectives whoops
pause the part I haven't showed you yet
is designed for what generally called a
hedge server the classic example of that
and I use an example of our environment
we have a hundred cameras scattered
around and no one's watching them
obviously we don't and it's too
expensive to send the bandwidth up to
the cloud and there's so we just
recorded and no one ever sees it but
with an edge server those hundred
cameras could be managed by a one box
running our chip and you could be
running object detection face detection
whatever you want looking for someone's
team's handy or whatever you want to do
we don't have a real application there
but there are lots of them so during
this development we actually worked with
the two companies one of which is a
standard security company has hundreds
of thousands of cameras around the world
but nothing happens the data is just
recorded and disappeared and they are
desperate for applications
that they can do and it's all edge
servers that are not sending all that
data to to the cloud our I don't know
how much you know about this area but we
decided that we were going to focus on
applications that did not need
retraining and that leaves out a lot of
great ideas are coming out in papers as
I said every day because those things
require retraining and at various points
we looked at some but the practice is
other than a few big giants normal
customers don't have ability to retrain
their applications so don't have the
money to retrain them are the technical
skills go go to us you know Amazon does
etc but kind of people that hire chip
usually don't so we decided to not count
on retraining what we were trying to do
is have the best performance per dollar
of any real system I make a comment on
here about something that gets a certain
level of rest now I mean there are
processors you can buy for 50 cents out
there right
maybe they got really good performance
for cost we have no idea we're talking
about real processors are real systems
and our goal was to have the best
performance per dollar period now what
we're not going to have yes the best
performance per watt and that is an
important metric in this industry it
affects some but it doesn't really
matter that much to an edge server our
Delta power just gets within the
envelope and it's not going to be low
because there's a problem the rest of
the processor sitting there plus we
optimized for performance not for power
and that does make a difference in your
design and we're not going to have the
best raw performance as I mentioned
there are people out there that are
building massive chips that will cost
literally thousands of dollars a chip
and then they're certainly within bidi
you can spend thousands and thousands of
dollars on their designs and they have
very good performance that was not well
we were aiming at
yeah what's that
where's Oh natural language yeah sorry I
mention that because image is the
obvious application here in fact its
application I just mentioned with my
hundred cameras but we're interested in
the future and we think the future is in
LP and it turns out NOP is much much
much much harder than image and so in
fact I'll show you later we have running
and submitter to a benchmark we were the
only chip company submitted this
benchmark of a Google neural machine
translation application that does
translation just as an example and one
other thing here which is latency we
think you know edge server latency is
important not just frames per second
that in the image world you can get good
scores by massive batching which is all
the GPUs do and naturally we do batching
too but we thought it was very important
what the latency per image is and so we
did some special things for that since
performance was so important to us we
just a lot on what we call a Mac
efficiency so it's obvious but I want to
talk a little bit about art and what its
implications are all we're talking about
is you know if you run for a second and
you're running at umpteen Tara Macs and
have up team Tara maps of performance
available to you but the application
doesn't use those maps all the time in
fact I comment up here that the
efficiency is not nearly as good as you
think yeah
yeah object detection classic image
classification object detection so one
of the first things we did was go out
buy equipment obviously and study what
was happening and we think included that
the leverage I say on the chart or Mac
is a Mac you're not going to build a
better iMac they all right on one
o'clock at least for integer and you
just have as many of them as you have
thousands typically these the trick we
think is data there's a lot of data
manipulation here I'm packing unpacking
reshaping three dimensional arrays to
the shape of your neurons etc and so
from the start and you'll see it later
when I talk about what we actually did
we decide to put spindle some of our
Hardware on doing those operations in
fact I mentioned it here we designed our
convolutional algorithms and our hard
our data movement Hardware together and
they're sort of funny but they work
really well and we get higher efficiency
I'm not gonna quote efficiency numbers
but we get like 25 percent more than a
lot of people in this industry in terms
of the efficiency we also someone
mention Amdahl plawer we also remember
it too and we have done hardware for all
the things that don't happen very often
but when they happen in a CPU they're
quite slow and so we added hardware to
speed those up these are the things we
had to decide on how how the coprocessor
is going to talk to software or how it's
going to talk to and the application
what how much we're going to spend on
things we know about which is image I
mean how much we're going to spend on
other things
memory is a big deal well that'll be
obvious I mentioned the data function
that was invention schedule we don't see
anyone else that's doing the kind of
things that we thought needed to be done
I will highlight one thing which is a
coprocessor issue as I said this started
being just a corner of another chip and
no one knew how big the corner was and
so scalability was really important to
us we had to fit and I'm gonna talk a
little bit about that that all it says
on a future chart that we had three
different sizes during our design
process where we had design for this in
heaven redo it so that was a key thing
we had to decide how to do and of course
the first question that people usually
ask me is what did you do a systolic
array a distributed set of course bla
bla bla and I'll mention that we did
something different than most but it's
the most obvious thing to do okay so now
I'm going to talk about what we did
there it's a CH a chip it's got eight
cores 16 mega memory now the cores are
pretty modern there are for issue
coerced a have 10 functional units that
the instructions are issued to you know
pretty close to a reasonably modern
intel part we compare sort of with one
particular part as Co dam has well but
in addition to what that part has we
also added avx-512 which is Intel's 64
byte wide Cindy architecture we have
four memory controllers it's just medium
lots of PCI lanes because in this edge
server world there's lots of devices you
want to cause 44 it's a lot and actually
has a pretty hefty cost as you'll see
when we get to some charts this is her
it runs at two-and-a-half gigahertz now
that may sound
slow when you can buy an Intel apart for
four gigahertz but that Intel part
doesn't run or four gigahertz all the
time it
realistically we're using I hate to say
it on television but old and slow
technology
this isn't six 16 nanometer FFC which is
not the fast 16 nanometer stuff from
TSMC and today you can read about people
that are in seven nanometer and go into
five nanometer as are we but this part
is in a relatively slow technology
because that's what we had so
two-and-a-half gigahertz is pretty good
in my opinion also this does support
duodai our dual socket which is a big
deal in the server industry you know two
parts almost all the server boards have
two parts so it's pretty obvious where
we're going to attach our coprocessors
can attach to the Rings the Rings are
the glue that ties everything together
therefore there's tools they go in
opposite direction 64 bytes wide running
at clock speed and it's just as you
suspect you put a token on the ring and
say I'd like to read I'd like the data
at this address and after a while the
data at that address comes back
everyone's on the Ring sees that request
and the right guy responds to it so it's
a perfect internal architecture for a
coprocessor there is our die and you
could actually see the eight cores vo3
and the i/o but I have overlay on it I
make it more clear so at the top of the
44 lines apiece yet yeah and you can see
across the top the drivers PC is pretty
fast drivers are pretty big and it's a
lot of them up there
and at the bottom is that you can see
the four DRAM controllers they also have
a lot of
as you can see the drivers creeping
along the bottom the there's four cores
on either side and the course have
attached to them a lump of the oh three
so the all three is in the middle there
and over on the left is what became of
our coprocessor I'm gonna mention later
about the compute versus RAM size and
the truth is we ended up with more size
than we thought so we filled with RAM
but I'll talk about that but you can see
the size of the compute unit and how we
and if we hadn't been there I'm not
saying all that space is for free but
you can see it's a major reshaping to
get all those pins into the part and
consume that space okay I'm going to
talk about connectivity because that's
very important so the coprocessor
appears to be a PCI device follows all
the rules of PCI device does PCI
configuration it's got a memory mapped
address space of 32 Meg's so like any
other PC I device at boot time it just
grabs that much address space and it's
there the yes that's about all that
chart says there's two ways to talk to
that people talk to it
the core can directly read and write
through that address space to memory you
notice memory appears down below so
there's memory and the in our neural
engine and there's compute the arrows
indicate that our memories I'll come to
later actually has to read ports in one
write port so that's in the middle there
but the x86 can send data to memory read
data out of the rams can also reads data
you know status registers can write
control registers all the things you'd
you'd suspect and the in core can also
interrupt back to x86 so it can demand
action if you will
then we have to DMA engines we read in a
right and those DMA engines can again
talk to things on the ring there's some
special cases I'll mention in a second
and they do it as you it's driven by the
program itself the program will say
please start a read to this address of
this many megabytes and use tag 13 you
know and later LLL wait on tag 13 and
the DMA is running all the time that's
got a lot of optimizations and there and
there are mapping registers in the PCI
config space this help map it into the
right right place so and you can see
that DMA is writing to RAM reading
things outer Ram the program the compute
part of its controlling it etc and all
these things are running at the same
time the program both buses and this was
actually the hardest part of the design
to do I'm speaking out as a hardware
designer of this it wasn't designing the
compute engine it was making all this
stuff work
obviously there's contention for the RAM
we have more buses than our ports on the
RAM so obviously stalls and things had
to happen most of the time everything is
running the device driver is sending
data in the DMA is reading data in the
compute engine is reading or writing the
Rams it shows up there that we don't
talk to IO there's nothing we could the
ring is capable but we can write to DRAM
we can read from DRAM and we can read
from the l3 caches so again the device
driver is prefetching in the caches etc
just affect so that's our connectivity
it's
we think fairly robust and obviously
there's a device driver that goes with
it I'll show that later that helps
manage all that so I mentioned that we
had to have something that was scalable
and flexible and we jump immediately to
the third bullet and what we did was use
a sim D architecture now I'm gonna show
show it it's extremely efficient in size
and it's very scalable you just do
vertical slices of it you know I'm
jumping ahead but we have four thousand
neurons so it's four thousand bytes wide
thirty-two thousand get wide sim D so
you can slice it at various points and
we have done that and it's just a slice
and you can then build with that
it's got good latency all four thousand
or all four thousand accumulators are
visible at the same time and it fits
into our processor mentality now we also
decided to run as fast as we could at
least up to the speed of the rest of the
chip because that we were limited in
area and speed equals performance so the
this is a simple chart that since Jared
what we have is the slices and a central
spine connecting them you'll see a real
picture in a second now what happened is
we had more vertical area we added more
ram the ram went vertically and as you
notice we ended up with a lot of RAM on
the park as we got more horizontal area
I assume you know that on a chip not
everything's equal is that the array is
only go one way
they can't be rotated etc as we got more
horizontal space we added more slices
and the spine is just wires and buffers
connecting things except the thing that
you it's Emily so there's only one
instruction controlling all of them so
the instruction processor is down in
this
my Nan's fanning out so where did we end
up with oh by the way there's where I
mentioned that we had three different
sizes during development or we had to
change the the number of neurons we had
and the slice architecture what we ended
up with was a thing and it's gonna look
just like this in a second which is 16
slices they're 256 bytes each so it's
4,000 bytes
AVX 32 768 to compare with Intel's
avx-512 runs a two and a half gigahertz
which yes 20 tera ops a second but again
I point out it's that serve a specimen
ship number of what's more important is
that that's more scores because the
efficiency varies so much on different
benchmarks and different architectures
we ended up with 16 mega RAM which is a
lot but realistically there's only one
or two simple applications that will fit
in that round most of the applications
have more RAM than that and that's why
we spend our time on the connectivity
and the DMA we're going to see that
picture later explain what's in it
basically the compute part the slices
are there in the middle you can see the
central spine there and the RAM is a
sticks above and below okay
so we've reached the point where I'm
going to talk about what's in there the
architecture
that's we have four basic blocks there
pipelined there's one instruction
processor that generates the controls
for the pipeline and the whole thing is
4,000 bytes wide there are some
interconnections across that which I'll
mention that because they're special now
you notice how small the instruction
memory is an instruction here I'll talk
more about later is actually 128 bits so
it's got a lot of functionality in it
because it controls the entire pipeline
and every instruction branches in one of
these architectures so one of the things
we had to do is make sure branches took
the 0 'clock so just as that required so
this thing is a the programs are not
very big in the sense of this is a
convolution and it runs for so long you
don't even notice loading in the memory
the instructions for the next
convolution everything works on one
clock I'm those the NP und U and rams
I'm going to talk about our loops that
is the output has to be available for
the input of the next clock and so there
are 1 clock by definition that's in the
instructions control DMA now there is
one exception to the one clock I'll
mention it on out the out you know does
activations and other things that
happened only once in a while back my
Amdahl's law we try to make them fast
but they don't happen but once every few
million clocks or so and so that's
actually internally sub multiplexed but
the pipeline above that can continue to
run at full speed
this chart just someone wants in a
presentation excuse me of something
because I said everything runs in one
clock well all the functional units
really are one clock but in between the
functional units you have to you know
you have this giant span of stuff you
have to move around or extra clocks but
it doesn't matter until you get
something that is written up pipeline
and that happens very very rarely there
are no branches here so you don't have
to worry about cost of a branch
misprediction and once every convolution
using image at the end of every
convolution which is typically millions
of calculations you do an output and so
you have to wait wait for that but the
code almost never Waits because you can
start the next convolution overlap with
where you are there's a variety of
memory synchronization then just allow
you to do that okay
the Rams there's two of them provide to
read ports each read four can read every
clock there's rights or rarer so there's
only one right port into them the buses
are reading and writing but those are
all buffered up until we get an entire
row a row to us as 4000 bytes that's the
width of this thing so everything is
incoming data from the buses is only 64
bytes so you buffered up till you have a
entire row that's 64 and then you dump
it in one clock so there's really little
interference here from the run the buses
and we actually have implemented ECC on
the memory because it's big enough that
we thought that should do that one of
the key things and I'm not really
talking about the instruction set here
much is
very rich addressing functions are
needed if you look inside of this when
it's running it's got you know five DMA
is running it's got you know five
different parts of the convolution
overlaps so we have a lot of addressing
a lot of index registers a lot of
powerful addressing mechanisms and the
instructions in this is always a
question comes up should be obvious but
this memory is not coherent it belongs
to in quartz up to the in core
application and device driver to manage
it yet why is that well first of all it
be terribly costly to make it coherent
costly in size and performance and
second of all quite honestly when we
started it seemed obvious it should be
after we worked out a lot of stuff it
was obvious that it didn't need to be in
it's been not an issue at all we also
point out interesting enough if you the
RAM is available sort of all the time so
if we can use this a scratch pad for
applications and things like that
okay the neural data unit is we think
and I've got a second chart on it the
key to our efficiency it has lots it has
a lot of inputs it only has four output
registers so see they're the world's
smallest register file or the world's
largest because it's four which is the
smallest so it's four by four thousand
or sixteen thousand bytes of register
file and what it go and it does a whole
bunch of stuff in parallel it does I'm
going to talk more about this but it
does rotate to disk compression factor
pooling you know shoving pipes back
together it does broadcast which is key
to our convolution algorithm basically
taking one bite out of a incoming block
and replicating it our convolutions work
that way
and then on the next clock it'll take a
second PI them replicated etc there's a
lot of functionality there it can do
merging of two things using a mask which
was a calculator mask that's usage these
are functions that we didn't been out of
it
didn't invent on day one these are
function became clearer when we started
looking at the application code and
everything works on one o'clock this is
from a hardware viewpoint one of the
great miracles of life I mentioned these
things every clock things are being done
here are the ones that are being done
most often almost every clock or a
broadcast at a rotate the rotates part
of the you know reshaping the data merge
compress some other things there I
mentioned that the convolution algorithm
is designed around this be cast function
which is very easy to do but very
powerful and vice versa and we also use
the x86 course to prepare data or the
internal formats of the waves and things
are in the form such weights don't
matter we put them in the format or we
reshape them and the application is
loaded in that format we needed and let
the x86 cores do some work there the
neural processing unit mpu does what
you'd expect it does max and a number of
other things we support three data size
as eight bits which is really a 9 bit
calculation a 16 bit integer and the new
floating point 16 bit floating point
called B float16 an integer math takes
an 8-bit integer Mac takes one clock
floating point Mac takes three clocks
which i think is pretty typical
we have predication which we use quite a
bit
and the thing a variety of things min
and Max for pooling and things like that
the accumulator is 32 bits and it's in
either a 32 bit integer or 32 bit single
precision floating point if we do in
floating-point and when you're an
integer it's saturating that doesn't
wrap around we did a lot of early on we
did a lot of calculations proving to
ourselves that the accumulators didn't
need to be 32 bits but we did it anyway
and then when we got around to doing
floating-point that of course that was
convenient in addition to the inputs
that come from the four output registers
of the move unit the data is also can be
moved from what the input from one
neuron is registered and moved to the
next neuron and that's also part of our
convolution scheme fairly typical think
of the classical fully connected neural
network its ripple the data down through
all the neurons each one getting a
different way to we happen to do our
8-bit quantization on the way input can
be done differently
the output unit is one of the most ugly
or complicated does what yes okay so
first of all we have to do quantization
and I spin an in normal in northern
about about it time on quantization
reading other Google Code and things
like that
trying to get it down right but does
quantization most coming from either
yeah Google or PI torch it does a number
of the popular activations breathe oh
and a number of variations on Rio you
can do you know I really love it doesn't
always clip to 0 kind of thing it does
hyperbolic tangent and sigmoid which are
somewhat falling out of favor but
they're still there and we do them it's
got a couple output registers again when
I say registers I mean 4,000 bytes here
right and that everything Cindy it can
also just store the accumulators back in
the memory and a variety of different
things and as I said things take one
o'clock or three clocks have been how
complicated they are but we typically
will multiplex at eight to one so yeah
after but it's pipeline so it's still
quite fast this is a catch-all I'm not
admitting to a foe on but if there was a
follow-on it would have even more stuff
right like a divide for softmax and
things like that that means anything
people out repair but when they happen
the Pipeline above continues to run and
the software takes advantage of that to
overlap them so all those annoying
little things sort of disappear from our
performance viewpoint implementation
challenges it sounds easy to say 32,000
bit wide data path the hardness of it is
not on any
it's on getting the whole thing
connected together you remember you got
input data coming in that's got to get
distributed a right piece of RAM
you've got instructions coming in which
have to go to all slices etc so a
substantial amount of the archeo it's
just managing hooking everything
together the two and a half gigahertz is
a challenge I'd point out that no other
neural thing that we know of runs
anywhere near that fast
typical Nvidia things are less than two
gigahertz and a lot of the new things
are running slower than that now in
fairness they're probably making them
power vs Meg arts trade-offs that's an
example I'll pick the sequencer
remember I said branches have to be done
in zero clocks so first you've got to
fetch the data so you have a register
for the address data just pours out
other RAM and then you've got to decode
it and figure out is it branching and
what branch is that we have call returns
we have regular branches we have looping
we have stalls you know basically
there's a 6 to 1 MUX I think on the
branch of this and to get the branch
address and send it back around for the
next fish and that left a hundred and
fifty Pico seconds to do decode and
branch selection which is not much in
this technology that's just an example
the end of you I'll point out in the
picture coming up is a lot of wiring you
know all those function compress be cast
rotated they're just lots of water lots
of muxing and of course wires are
slowing in the modern technology the
Rams were challenged by themselves
without getting into detail there's four
different people that can write to them
four different people that can read to
them getting all that data distributed
stage because the RAM still have to work
in one clock so if you write to the RAM
the data so they'll both the next clock
this was a build
masterpiece we happen to have a very
very good the old person and he and I
work well together the RTL and the build
were done you know hand in glove
every single day kind of thing it's just
that type of thing
that you get to when you're trying to
make something four thousand bytes wide
and small there it is the Iowa is all
coming in on the right just about a
little over two thousand pins of ioho
and it is processed down the middle do
you see the sequencer which I put a box
around that's the entire instruction
processor clinic including the
instruction Rams there in there you can
see the Rams are on the top and the
bottom to the right of the sequencer
there's a couple of arrays you can see
they're black little things there those
are five O's for the memory data because
the memory data can't interfere it needs
to write to the RAM but the instruction
is reading from that Ram and so you have
to stall something and that spine there
is just filled with wires and registers
and buffers moving data around to the
left of the sequencer is a thousand deep
laud array which again if we were doing
something else would make a lot bigger I
didn't talk about it here but one of the
challenges of a design like this is
debug or knowing what's going on
right and so we put I put in every debug
function that I'm used to from a
processor but one of the most powerful
ones that we use heavily is a clock by
clock log this is which is that thing on
the left as it turned out again we had
more room than at the end and we thought
the 16 slices can to be seen and one
what the trained eye can notice the
slice is that the ends are different
than the slices in the middle I
mentioned rotate so
I'll probably lose this these two things
are moving data both directions right
well when you get to here the data has
to be moved up and you can see some of
the wiring creep you know that this is
only three levels of metal any more than
the evidence becomes opaque the the
bright green there is the moon is the
data units that are almost all wire I
mean there's obviously some registers
there but it's just literally tens of
thousands of weird shaped muck to think
of compress right take something and we
do several different comprising the
cheetah one three two one etc now seas
of muxes and that's what's going on in
the green there I guess and the non
green is compute all right now as I set
up above that's about eleven square
millimeters and 16 nanometers in five
nanometers which the world's enamored of
that would be about a third that size
you know the size rejection is more than
2 X closer 3 X it's about 20 million and
gates
okay code I say this all hardware I'll
get a little bit of code here that's a
real hunk of code up there sort of looks
like a high-level language it's in an
internal thing we call smart assembler
but that's what a one-step of a
convolution looks like and it says down
below what it is it's going to get some
weight weight data it's gonna do a be
cast to create the 64 replicate about 64
times then it's going to use that data
with the back using as the data the
input to the next lower number while
it's doing that it's going to rotate
four thousand by row because it's not
needed here but it's getting ready for
the next use and this instruction is
going to execute four times it's got a
loop so we have standard looping stuff
and some variation of that is the heart
of convolutions that been polished and
and studied and hardware is very
efficient for those I mentioned lie
there we don't read the data every time
the instruction says read the data but
since we know we already read the data
and it's grown away in yet another place
and just automatically appears what
about what our real instructions look
like they're 128 bits and I listed
therefore you know the for the type of
instruction that did that convolution
step a second ago roughly how many bits
are used and the truth is that the
average instruction might use 64 to 80
bits but there's some that need almost
all all of them the instruction set is
Hardware dependent this very low-level
we follow the theory that the eighth
this is perhaps controversial but that
the goal of software is to simplify
hardware hardware guy what can I say but
fortunately this the software that does
this is not as I said it's not going to
be made public and no to worry about it
because we actually have tools and we
have a software stack so finally we get
to my software chart we started off I
started off PI torch wasn't that
exciting it wasn't that big a deal as it
is now tensor flow was we thought the
best approach so the blue up there
yes standard Google tensor flow stuff
there's David toca tensor flow light
compiler and they have a tensor flow
like interpreter which has a thing
called Adelie get function which allows
you to basically replace any step you
know with your own stuff get software or
hardware so we use that the orange is
our stuff there's some graft level
optimizations it you'd suspect because
the hardware can do certain things
together etc and the nkl is the
low-level neural Karl library and that's
where knowledge of the instruction set
is inside our there is hundreds of
different congress routines of
convolution a dot thirteen right V dot
seventeen with different sizes different
things all coated by hand by one of
these really smart
new UT students we have and all that
comes together with the user data in our
end our code into a thing called a
little it is a famous giant structure
and then there's the x86 runtime library
we actually did a lot of optimization on
that's a success since we do x86
processors were fairly fluent in
optimizing x86 code or understand its
performance so we did a lot of
optimization it's doing things with
avx-512 that weren't publicly done in
avx-512 etc make our library and then we
have a Linux device driver which knows
about the interface and it's managing
allocating memory allocating the
processor and ultimately then the driver
is going to load both the in core
program and x86 program and have that
right and those two are talking together
moving data back and forth etc so this
is the chart that puts a lie to the fact
that I never talk about software the
proof of this is coming up so I'm going
to talk about the mo perf benchmarks and
their submission where we took off the
shelf if you will or off the benchmark
shelf
tensorflow code and rant several
applications and it worked because in
that D'Oench mark is all mentioned I
think you can't play with it you've got
to take it as it is and run it if you're
in the close category which we are so
that's what I want to talk about now so
there's an I assume you may or may not
know this there's a new benchmarking
soares up now and when I was younger I
went to all the conferences and all the
places and talked about how horrible
benchmarking was in our industry and it
is you know but I've been pleasantly
surprised with you know perfect Sanu
benchmarking consortium everyone
participates in it the unit when I say
everyone the universities all the
startups and all the all the big players
and they've got a close category where
you've got to take the code and the data
as it is not touch it not change it not
optimize it and run it and you have to
hit a certain level of accuracy
you know every day there's a new paper
someone comes out and says well I
figured out how to do you miss detection
with a half a bit right you know the
problem with all that is first of all
massive retraining and secondly accuracy
because you're quantizing away accuracy
when you do those things you have to hit
an accuracy target so running with this
stuff as it is and meeting the accuracy
are hard and after you do all that they
audit the teen function make sure you're
not cheating so I think this is all
great well the first submissions were
last October I'll make a point I'll come
up later my show numbers that this was
only a month after God we got working
Sullivan this is a really great effort
by by the team after we got the silicon
after arrived in the machine room yes
yeah as you know with I don't know if
you know I mean nothing works when it
gets back there's a million ten you know
modern processors and millions of
configuration things the DRAM the
processor the bad ones have to be weeded
out but you don't have a test program
that we dam out but then you do but then
the test program is bad you don't mean
you're a miracle if you have something
running
furia in a month so it was up what's
that well and we're not done with bring
bring out but I was just saying yes this
was a really forced march and I'm very
pleased with it there's a number of
categories and we submitted in the close
category the other only other chip
people that did it when until Nvidia
Qualcomm and centaur a lot of other
people AMD arm etc missing and the
results came out or published in months
later we're in the inference category
there's also training category and
training benchmarks there were five
benchmarks done and I listed up there
for interest the size of the weights and
the number of Max it took to process you
know one you know which is if a sentence
for NLP or an image for image and you
can see in natural machine well things
get very good get big in both max but
also and the data there was one we
submitted the four that are highlighted
there there was one other we just didn't
get to it's fairly straightforward now I
want to make a point that these are
popular names like ResNet resonate is
the standard benchmark in the image
world everyone quotes resonate and
they're all different we have a verse
and a ResNet yet thirty percent better
performance on in the version that ml
per house you know these are very very
specific things so I'm saying the
obvious the aware of vendor claims it's
easy to quote a ResNet score this is a
very specific reason that it is anyway
we submitted those four and we were the
only chip people to submit GMT now I'm
going to show you in a second our
numbers aren't fantastic but we did
because that's a something has massive
data and it's a recurrent neuron so call
or an image doesn't have any memory s
and that's obvious to you you're just
natural machines natural language
processing has to have memory it's what
you said before is matter now the last
word
next word etc and so there's been a lot
of work on neuron structures that
remember in fact we have some things
that are designed specifically to help
there and as a result it really takes
maybe three or four neurons to do one
neurons worth of work and these
recurring thanks so get it the GMT to
show that we could do it and as I said
it turned out we were the only one now
there's a lot of really good numbers
that were reported there were
configurations that cost tens of
thousands of dollars that's not us I
will compare to the thing that we in a
second that I think we compare best
closest to but it wasn't a great there
weren't any things are really exactly
like us and it goes without saying that
today our numbers are better than what
we submitted because we only have a
month but this is what I my chart will
compare to there was a new part from
Intel it's not a high end part but it
has it has this new instruction set
called VN ni from Intel designed for
inference save you X 512 thing it's as I
said a relatively low in thing does have
a built-in GPU the other thing is sort
of interestingness a new device came out
literally there wasn't it wasn't even
easily available that when we did this
from nvidia nvidia has a million GPUs
this is device that has several ARM
cores and is specifically aimed for
aimed at plug it into your piece into
your box and you have a computer it
happens to be an arm computer and it
does have a lot of hardware assist some
other processors there's a Qualcomm
Snapdragon we're not in there but you
know this this is a high-end phone chip
but we've included it because Snapdragon
is their architecture their our sim the
architecture
you want to see how well it did and then
most people are using a part that you
can't even really ordinary people can't
buy from Intel the best one is that 9282
which is a dual the things using that
used two of them each of them has 56
cores each of them has 12 memory
challenge you get the idea and I
actually compare it that because that's
something interesting just to see and
now down the bottom the week before we
submitted these numbers Intel announced
a new thing from they had bought a
company Nirvana announced a new device
it's a PCI device it has equivalent of
12 of our course it has 12 lumps of
4,000 neurons and then they use two
cores and I seen em they've now
withdrawing this other than to their top
customers because they have gone and
bought a company called Havana which has
a better solution than Nirvana
but anyway we compared with it oh this
is latency I won't won't be labored
except as you might suspect regular
processors like the Intel thing and the
Qualcomm they don't have great latency
either even the massive thing there on
the right doesn't have any better lake
and see than us
so latency was one of the things that
was measured by ml per F
again re-emphasize in its importance
okay the yellow numbers are what we
submitted the green numbers are roughly
what they are today our score on SSD
which is object detection was a
abnormally low because we just didn't
have time it's gone up a lot the others
are going up all right I mention to you
GMT is only 12 sentences a second and
that's the 12 is our number you normally
like to put on charts but given that no
one else did it at all
we compare we claim we're infinitely
faster yeah to two of those 56 that's
112 course totally 2424 memory channels
140 Meg of l3 I mean you know pretty
impressive but yet if I may be snide
they can't do a decent nor Oh
coprocessor they bought two companies
now trying to get a solution so you can
see that the Nvidia part and I put
approximately a thousand dollars I don't
know what it what it really cost you
don't never know in these things but
that's a fairer we think cost for it is
pretty good regular CPUs are pretty poor
the monster with 112 cores this lot
faster but what I do on the next chart
is normalize this and I realize just to
too many words there I'll get to the
punchline if you look at the Intel stuff
which has the world's best core it has
to a be X 512 within a none I that's new
instruction set you know most people are
looking at one a V X 512 like us they
have two per core plus this new
instruction set and we run at a
performance about equivalent to 24 of
their cores NRC enough they have a 24
core part that lists for $3,600 that has
all the stuff that we should be roughly
equivalent to but anyway we're just
doing numerology here but it's
reasonable to divide their score we let
these really good core is divided by the
number of cores and we find out that
that we're about equivalent to 24 their
cores a really good course and down the
bottom I pointed out that we get almost
1/4 the performance
- this thing that has equivalent of 12
of our cores on it has 12 times 4 K
neurons and we're giving 1/4 of that was
for K neurons again we're doing
efficiency Studies on all these things
and we're quite pleased with our
efficiency this is actually my last
chart what do we learn well
you expect me to be proud of our team
but I I mean Centaurs done things with a
very small team for ever and we just did
it again
a coprocessor approach is clearly a very
good idea we're getting a very good
performance in a very small area so
achieved all of our goals originally we
had to guess at what functions we wanted
to do and what the architecture wasn't
our guesses are pretty good so we feel
pleased with that
however in fairness now that we've got
running applications there are things we
see that could be done better the RAM is
slightly overkill on this maybe not
optimally shaped there are some
additional instruction features or more
likely into you features that we've come
across that need to be a domain to use
our data manipulation thing different
slice geometry might be better and we're
quite confident that if we were doing it
again we would get more performance in
the same area but still our performance
numbers are good the size is small and
we did it from scratch so obviously you
think it's a good effort so I'm shocked
I got no in depth questions
well I know all the questions I'm not
going to give them to you yeah the
question was do we consider if you will
make in a much wider avx-512 a simony
unit in the course and you can it added
in what you said there
it requires everything to change the l3
has to be wider they all to has to be
why are they all 1s we are these things
have to be fit with data well it still
has to be wider they are that the Intel
memory Harkey is as all goes around 64
byte lines a 64 that's why avx-512 is 64
bytes or by some versa it would tear up
the cores and we did consider it very
long there's enough special things it
not only have to do that you'd have to
add more of these more units you'd have
to add new instructions there's a lot of
things a lot of this weird stuff you do
that we do in these applications that
are efficient to do in x86 instruction
so you have to dad see basically you're
tearing up any similar to the core and
the software to run out it's a little
bit harder to do and what we did we had
the advantage of in a room there's net
one in and the software guys at the
other end until the software and the
hardware masked right you know fooling
within the enhancing
x86 architecture there's a lot of other
considerations you have to do you just
can't roll your your own that easily so
the real answer to question did we
consider making wider at avx-512 for
about one millisecond yeah the question
was will anyone well it was from
somebody by the way who claims to have a
nano laptop so we need to find the
details there the question was this um
you know went gonna buy it just for x86
or they always want to use the neural we
don't know as I said we have silicon
it's been demonstrated we're talking to
customers as we speak and I think the
jury's out on their one reason why we
took the approach that we did is we
didn't burden the x86 cores very much
with this and so personal just wants a
low cost edge server you know with eight
cores and 16 mega memory they got it but
if they want a decent you know if they
want the neural assist they got that too
so our approach is always quite simple
we'll sell whatever to anybody who has
nowhere that's all right well we don't
know yeah
well if our highlighted there we've
already identified quite a few and we
could get a lot more first of all
there's architecture changes regardless
of the size that I hint out there then
make it more efficient even at 4k wide
but we would get a lot more a lot more
function in a small area it's a third
it's roughly a third I'm an expert on
the technology it's lower power it's
faster and typically that just
translates to more but for us five
nanometers there's a ways away and so we
are looking at architectural things the
technology always comes the technology
you can always take advantage of by
doing more you know more cars more l3
etc that will happen sort of
automatically question yes
do we think people want to use this for
something other than the applications we
know maybe I mean the part it is what it
is and we did put in a number of sort of
extra things for flexibility but we
really haven't focused on that we had
our hands full again if you remember my
first chart the size of the team and how
much we've got running and hardware and
the applications we've done we've been
focused on that we did
along the way talk work with two other
groups or talk to them one was as I
mentioned a security camera that wants
to move into deep learning it's actually
got a name is called Cuba's just company
and they were good to work with the
other was I won't mention the name is a
company that does car things like
license plate detectors and things like
that you know every car must have and so
that was interesting because they learn
the requirements for car things what
comes of that I don't know yes oh it's
just multiple what's an act multiply
accumulate so that's the fundamental
atomizer no we don't know any radar guys
but that's that's one reasonable
question one is that we talk to other
people like radar guys that's one reason
I'm going around giving talks right we
are small company most people haven't
heard that's what we think we have
something useful is it applicable I
don't know it's doing a questionable
floating point this new be float 16
which I'm not sure everyone is fully
contemplated
yes
okay well names all Auto routed but it
was autorap yeah it was all Auto Rotter
but the RTO was knew a lot about
geometry in it the way it was written
now it's my RTO and the old guy is very
good applied you know these modern
billet rules have 2,000 parameters to
them he knew the right mm and we did a
lot of experimentation so no it's not
custom it's the only thing that's custom
in there are the arrays the razor the
Rams are custom but the slices are all
built using son offices tools but built
but someone who really knows them and
with with him and I one thing I learned
doing this versus other things I've done
is how much the build should affect RTL
and vice versa
you know it just so happens as a side
comment that the build go I was the
first Center employee 25 years ago so we
can work together yes the question is
why are we hiding the instruction set
probably because we're going to change
it because the instruction set is
reflecting the detailed functions in the
neuron and particularly in the data unit
and we want the freedom you know I've
spent my whole life stuck with that you
know before this all the way back to IBM
when I was IBM fellow I was the IBM
representative to end
architecture matters so for 35 plus
years I've been stuck with an
instruction set where you can't change
anything because one day in 1978 someone
made it so we're trying to avoid that
this was our first effort he was you
know we're smarter now it's good or
product that we think it sell but we can
do we can do a better one and we want
the freedom to do that also we don't we
talk to customers and we haven't felt
well there's one potential customer
who's in who might be interested in
doing some experimentation with it etc
they're like but in general real
customers don't care about this they
want to know do you support pi torch and
you have these well I'll give you the
usual answer if someone has a good
reason to know it wants to do some
low-level stuff and if they have the
world the proper wherewithal of course
we'll expose it to them but as I said we
want we want the freedom to make it what
we want this is only release one and we
think this is a law has a life to it yes
yes this chip
this chip has the standard has a design
it's as a design license because we do
export piece of the design but does not
include no the question was other export
controls honor as a design license of a
manufacturing license to TSMC and a
product license the design license does
not include our neural we don't plan
right now to export than they're all I'm
not sure I should say so but one of
ordinary skill can read read a bit and
find out that we have exported our
designs in the past to another country
that shall remain nameless but we don't
did not export this and don't have any
plans to yes yes the question is can
this chip be used for training as well
as in France only in the sense of the
x86 course training today requires a
real floating-point 32-bit
floating-point I don't believe they're
trained with that but in any case it's
so if that's right then I miss if you
can train with a 16-bit D float then I'm
mistaken it's my impression I'm not an
expert in if it requires low
floating-point but again it requires so
much compute time to do training today
training on a 32 core part will take
days you know that kind of thing it's
just four thousand neurons it's not that
much but so we we haven't as far as I
know we haven't considered it but again
we're welcome to to anybody who has the
right stuff to play with it and try
things
that's really a question I'll I should
have had our AI expert Harvey's here on
the phone he could answer that better
than I can
yes the question is how do we test it we
tested it the old-fashioned way I
actually tried we have a very strong
formal verification team there and I did
have some formal verification done on
the instruction on the NP you but it's
after some point it went away so we
tested it the old-fashioned way unit
tests tested a human sits down writing
this 120 bit instructions tested
everything that they thought needed to
be tested and then we tested it using as
the software team developed the
tensorflow software we tested it using
not just real application but made up
things variations permutations so it was
tested the old-fashioned way which is
people writing tests and run in though
possible the floating-point for example
got a lot of extra testing for the bad
numbers there's a lot of bad numbers and
floating-point by bad I think not evil
but difficult numbers right things and
underflow Overflow Creek Nan's etc so
that got a fair amount of extra testing
but I'm not all I can say to you so
we've made no no we've had no problems
and hardware doesn't mean there aren't
any that just means that what we've
tested is what we're using right now
again one of the advantage it's back to
the question of why doe
want to expose the instruction set one
reason is as I mentioned I want to
change it the other is that leads to
weird bugs I mean again I spent 35 years
dealing with the fact you have to run
not only you have to run this
instruction set that's questionable on
several features you've got to run
software that someone wrote in 1986 we
we test 42 different operating systems
in the x86 part of us right by actual
count and somewhere people find where
things I'll tell you an anecdote of off
the point our first part the Intel
architecture has in the condition code a
lot of don't errors you know and the
first part we did we said well there
don't care so there don't cares and
within seconds the IBM Mouse driver
failed because it was using it don't
care flag after a multiply stuff like
that so we have spent a lot of the
reason why this is a side thing some in
our earlier thing today I had us on a
conference calls talking about the
difficulties of doing x86 and someone
asked someone implied that the reason
there's only three companies that do it
and tell AMD in us is because of patents
that's not true it's because of tribal
knowledge and the undocumented things
and what you learn over learned over 20
years of evolution so that to help avoid
that is another reason why I don't want
you to write programs for whoever you
are yes
yes well your bring the question was not
what not really a question observation
of strange images there's a whole a lot
of discussion of that as you know in the
industry because there's no some real
science behind this deep learning all
right you know you pour things in a
hopper it's all experimental and the
answer seemed to come out right but you
can't prove that tomorrow there's not a
image that says something wrong and I
won't get in
[Applause]